home alone is undeniably a Christmas
classic how could anyone not love it it
tells the story of a young boy Kevin
McAllister who's accidentally left
behind when his family leaves for a
Christmas vacation to make matters worse
two burglars have targeted the mallister
house while Kevin is there by himself
unfortunately that's also where things
kind of start to break down Kevin
defends his Homestead by setting up a
series of elaborate and dangerous traps
in order to stop the bad guys from
robbing the place instead of you know
calling the cop
and that's just one of the many dumb
things in Home Alone that everyone just
ignored call the police what's the first
thing that every kid learns to do when
they realize they're in danger didn't
they teach you that in school about 911
that you call if somebody needs help
yeah yeah either Kevin didn't get the
memo or he just doesn't have the mental
capacity of a four-year-old sure the
phone lines are down but he knows how to
get into town to go food shopping and he
knows exactly when Harry and Marv will
be robbing his house Kevin only dials
911 near the end of the film after the
crooks have made their way through
almost all of his traps even weirder
when he finally calls the cops he
disguises his voice and tells them his
neighbor address why was that the plan
did he think the cops would hear a
child's voice calling for help on 911
and they wouldn't come or maybe it's
because the cops in this town suck oh
he's just home alone and I would like
somebody to go over to the house and see
that he's all right just to check on
him you want us to go to your house just
to check on him the cops of Home Alone
are basically garbage with badges when
they're informed about a small child
left without supervision they send one
police officer to the mallister house
the cop knocks on the door and then
arbitrarily decides Kevin's mom just
can't keep track of her children because
no one answers maybe that's why the wet
Bandits don't seem concerned in the
slightest when Kevin makes multiple
threats to call the police Harry and
Marv simply ignore Kevin and continue to
invade his home they're already guilty
of breaking and entering and they're
attempting to assault a minor so the
charges would probably be pretty severe
but because Kevin lives in a town full
of PA blarts there's really no reason
for them to worry even the pizza boy has
lost hope Home Alone must happen in some
dystopia and alternate reality where the
law simply doesn't matter when Kevin
plays the audio from an old gangster
movie to make the pizza guy think he's
about to get murdered there are
absolutely no
consequences
apparently this kid just went back to
delivering more pizzas and never warned
anyone about the spray of gunfire that
just took out half the neighborhood's
inflatable Santas Marv doesn't know how
TV works the Pizza Boy scene is weird
but Kevin uses the same trick on Marv as
he tries to break in the back door it
worked on the especially stupid pizza
boy because Kevin only played certain
parts of the conversation making the
Pizza Boy believe that he was talking to
a real person and we all know the pizza
boys are dumb people said I was dumb but
I prove them but when Marv comes to the
door Kevin just plays the movie sure
Kevin has his own special effects but
has Marv never heard of a TV before how
does this work why is this happening it
it's just real life Uncle Frank is a
monster so we've talked about how the
movie Suburban hellscape is filled with
morons but we can't let Kevin's Clan off
the hook the mallister family is a bunch
of hot garbage while it makes sense that
Kevin might get picked on by his older
siblings and cousins why are the adult
mallister straight up bullying an
8-year-old when it comes to the steaming
pile of awful human trash that is this
family Uncle Frank lives at the top when
Kevin gets into a fight with Buzz who
was pretending to throw up on Kevin by
the way some soda gets spilled on Uncle
Frank's lap Kevin didn't even do it it
was Kevin's useless dad so naturally
Uncle Frank loses it look what you did
you little jerk
nobody defends Kevin not his parents not
even the kid from Pete and Pete Kevin
you're such a disease Frank is a
middle-aged adult with some very deep
psychological issues forget Harry and
Marv if anyone deserves a nail through
the foot it's Frank the mcallisters may
all be monsters Kevin's mom has to rush
back home because they can't get in
touch with anybody to look in on Kevin
but how is that possible the entire town
didn't go away for Christmas Kevin goes
to school and even mentions that he has
friends so why can't his parents call
one of their families or any of the
friends of Kevin's 7,000 siblings is
there literally no one in the entire
state of Illinois that the mcallisters
can trust to check up on Kevin Kevin is
going to kill his family remember how
Harry and Marv kept falling down the
stairs because they were covered with
ice or how the basement steps were
covered in tar and Nails Kevin's massive
family was basically walking into a
death trap by the end of the movie Kevin
isn't exactly the most conscientious kid
and he's even pretty happy about the
possibility that he psychically murdered
them I made my family disappear so it's
incredibly unlikely the kid cleaned up
after himself hopefully Uncle Frank
cracks his melon on those icy steps
first hey pizza is here you go that's
12250 it's my brother's house he'll take
care of it your name's Kevin you know
what they're going to call you in France
don't you huh no
[Music]
yeah we really hate that
guy in a turn of events that surprised
exactly no one Star Wars the Force
awakens became one of the biggest hits
of the past several years and scor some
pretty great reviews to boot it borrowed
heavily from the first Star Wars film
sure but it sprinkled enough fresh ideas
to balance out the Nostalgia perfectly
so the film is pretty great but that
doesn't mean there aren't a few things
in there that might make you scratch
your head here are the dumb things we
all ignore in Star Wars the Force
awakens so what's the first ord's whole
deal anyway in the original Star Wars
Trilogy the Rebellion fights for freedom
from the tyranny of the Empire The
Empire is well an Empire it's a huge
evil government that rules the Galaxy
with an iron fist makes sense right but
in the force awakens it's the resistance
that fights against the first order and
the first order is what exactly if the
Rebellion defeated the Empire and the
Galaxy is now governed by the new
Republic then what the heck is the first
order what do they do and why and where
they get the resources to build an
entire planet made of death stars
curious fans can hit up Google for the
first orders unexplained backstory but
seriously we shouldn't have to chase
down the answers to some pretty basic
questions by digging into the force
awakens visual dictionary that kids buy
at elementary school book Bears R2D2's
perfect timing that little data file
that led to Luke's hidden location
served as a great carrot to dangle in
front of everyone and keep this movie uh
rolling if there's one thing Star Wars
does great it's hiding important
information in adorable robots what
message the one you've just been playing
the one you're carrying inside your
rusty in but bb-8 only has a piece of
the map so naturally the little guy
wonders about the other Droid who spent
some time as a rolling flash drive R2-D2
in fact he asks R2 about whether or not
he's got the rest of the map everybody
needs and then this happens you're
wasting your
time it is very doubtful that U would
have the rest of the map in his backup
data I am afraid not U2 has been in low
power mode ever since Master Luke went
away but C3PO is totally wrong as we
find out at the end of the film when R2
suddenly wakes up just in time to put
everybody back into a good mood that's
great timing R2 but hadn't the
resistance ever tried to look through
r2's memory before he literally has a
computer for a brain nobody dug out a
USB cable and plugged him into the
computer no one in the resistance is
heard of controll f Captain fasma is not
very fantastic Captain fasma is
undeniably cool what with her shiny
armor fany cape and Slick British accent
and then she goes down like a sack of
potatoes and then she pretty much caves
immediately Finn tells her to bring down
the shields across the base and she does
it without a fight did she only get that
fancy Stormtrooper suit because she's
like general hux's cousin or something H
don't need parachutes remember when Finn
and po crash land on jaku and Finn takes
Po's jacket from the smoking wreckage it
sure seemed like Po was dead until he
showed up again for the last Act of the
movie we never find out how he survived
or even why he left his style and jacket
behind the reason po was actually dead
at least in the first bunch of drafts of
the screenplay apparently director JJ
Abrams was was so taken with Oscar
Isaac's performance he decided to keep
po around after all too bad we can't say
the same for every pilot in Star Wars of
course cover me Porkins I'm right with
you red three no problem
here I can hold it pull up no I'm
all sorry Porkins should have been
handsomer a convenient Chasm the film
ends with a climactic battle between Ray
and kylo ren as she takes the emo Vader
wannab be to the Woodshed by the end of
the fight kylo Ren has a few holes in
him and Ray is triumphant then a very
convenient hole opens up right between
them allowing Ren to be rescued before
the Star Killer base explodes this of
course is highly symbolic of the
ideological divide between Reay and kylo
ren one has embarked on the path of the
Jedi while the other has turned his back
on it forever good versus evil dark
versus light oh and keeping your
exciting new bad guy alive so he can
come back and give Your Heroes a hard
time in the seet
too bad we can't say the same for every
exciting new bad guy in Star Wars of
[Music]
course sorry Darth Maul should have been
uh kylo
renier The Hunger Games did a lot of
things right Faithfully adapting Suzanne
Collins best-selling books into a
blockbuster franchise that launched
Jennifer Lawrence into worldwide super
St status but as good as it was it
didn't quite do everything right here's
a look at some dumb things everyone
ignores about The Hunger Games
idiocracy the basic concept of The
Hunger Games takes some suspension of
disbelief to buy into but even then the
politics don't really make much sense
think about this the folks in the
districts do all the hard labor to keep
the rich people in the capital flush
with food and coal and amazing hair dyes
considering they need the workers in the
districts to keep working wouldn't it
make way more sense to actually you know
feed them enough to do that work plus
given how technologically advanced the
capital is using just a little bit of
that knowhow to help automate things
like coal mining would significantly
boost productivity while also raising
quality of life and morale in the
districts acting like a bunch of evil
jerks might be fun but it doesn't make
good business sense drinking games when
we first met hitch he's pretty much a
useless snarky drunk with no interest in
helping Katniss and Peta figure out how
to survive when the fighting begins then
the next morning jerk face is gone and
has suddenly been replaced by a helpful
wise Mentor who whips The District 12
team into shape that change happens
literally overnight so maybe all hitch
needed that whole time was a good
breakfast coaching fail speaking of
hitch he's apparently the smartest dude
in the entire country because when the
games actually begin the contestants
from every other District act like a
bunch of idiots hach's big piece of
advice is to ignore the supplies at the
cornicopia and just run for the woods
because it's going to be a blood bath as
the others fight over the goodies and it
[Music]
is it seems obvious but apparently the
mentors in other districts didn't think
to pass this nugget of wisdom along to
their kids because sure enough a bunch
of them get creamed in the first 30
seconds maybe their mentors were even
drunker than haitch Wait no that's
impossible it's well after breakfast by
this point burn baby burn a pivotal
moment in The Hunger Games takes place
when Katniss is chased up a tree by a
pack of other contestants after a
half-hearted effort to kill her Peta
convinces them to just make a campfire
and wait for her to die of like old age
or something that turns out to be a bad
plan because through a complete Stroke
of Luck Katniss finds a conveniently
placed Hive full of genetically modified
be
which she drops on their dumb heads I
think those are tracker jackers Am I
Wrong
oh those things are very lethal very but
if those kids can make fire why didn't
they just you know Set Fire to the tree
trees are made of wood right even in the
future and if the Flames didn't get her
the smoke probably would have or at
least forced her to jump which probably
would have hurt her pretty bad way to go
you dead dumb Dums cak Wars Peta may not
be the most useful guy with a weapon but
he sure is one hell of a painter he
shows off his incredible camouflage
Artistry during training and again uses
it to go Incognito After suffering a
pretty substantial sword wound of the
leg we're told he picked up this rare
and impressive skill by decorating cakes
at The District 12 Bakery really I uh I
used to decorate the cakes down with the
bakery huh so does that mean the US
military should be tapping the
camouflage skills of Duff Ace of Cakes
Goldman should Cake Boss be teaching
courses to Army cadets at West Point
about how to disguise yourself as a
giant edible pink rose for combat
reasons just how the hell does baking
and decorating cakes teach a kid how to
go full-on Mudman listen Peta we're
calling shenanigans the amount of effort
and talent it would take to create that
spotless camouflage is a whole lot more
than you'd pick up by writing happy
birthday here's a cal cake a few times a
week with an icing squirter plus since
we're on the subject how would anyone in
district 12 which is entirely made up of
starving coal miners have the cash to
get a
cake when it comes to popcorn movies the
phrase dumb fun might get used by fans
and a lot of people found Suicide Squad
to be just that dumb fun but was there
just a bit too much dumb with a
collection of A-list actors as
ridiculous comic bad guys you'd think
it'd be hard to get it wrong and while
the result has some great moments the
final cut that made it to the Silver
Screen was reportedly wrecked by the
studio making Cuts while you may have
seen the extended edition at home here
are some dumb things in the theatrical
version of Suicide Squad that everyone
just ignored the Magic Machine
enchantress exists so the suicide squad
can go up against the sexy villain with
the generic plan please don't touch me
please don't touch me her big evil idea
build a mysterious machine to in mankind
and that's pretty much it the device
apparently powered by enchantress's
sweet dance moves and make out sessions
is never actually explained she just
says she's going to create a giant
garbage tornado to get back at Humanity
then it opens up a hole in the sky
enchantress can transform any human into
a member of her jelly Army and her
brother has Crazy Fire whips for arms
that can slice through anything if you
can't take over the world with just that
you're doing it wrong Lady Justice
League who by the time Suicide Squad
rolled Round The Flash and Wonder Woman
were already introduced to movie
audiences to have them disappear during
one of the biggest metahuman crises the
world has ever seen doesn't quite add up
it would have been simpler to set the
film Prem Mana steel than to pretend
that these Heroes didn't exist for the
big fight of Suicide Squad we could
accept if Batman called in sick after
learning his lesson about not fighting
superpowered
villains but no wonder woman she's all
about this kind of stuff the helicopter
after crash suspension to disbelief is
pretty critical when viewing any
superhero film but that doesn't mean you
have to toss out everything you know
about physics and biology in the name of
action-packed Evil Shenanigans Evil
Shenanigans when the suicide squad's
helicopter is shot down as they're
entering the city and does about a dozen
flips on the ground you'd expect a
broken fingernail at the very least the
super tough Killer Croc might come out
okay but somehow everyone hops out of
the downed copter like they're fresh out
of the shower what a ride got we know
the are bad guys but there's no way that
someone didn't at least bang a knee in
that
[Music]
crash
a we'll say it again we're calling
shenanigans you mean Shenanigans
no the only bomb in the universe the
first attempt at blowing up Incubus
failed because enchantress cut out on
the team moments before the bad guy
destroying bomb went off with no way to
reset the countdown instead of in the
bomb for 5 minutes or something they
base an entire plan around an unreliable
magical weirdo you must just say the
whole thing was a bad idea even stranger
they only have one of these bombs and
somehow can't make another so they have
to retrieve it from a flooded subway
system at the very least this makes
Killer Croc swimming uh Powers actually
relevant but it's never explain why this
one bomb is the only bomb or why wiping
out the building from above isn't an
option or why don't they just use a
drone or something why must the squad do
everything the hard way we're bad guys
it's what we do oh okay then terrible
admissions policy Amanda Waller's entire
reason for assembling The Suicide Squad
was so she could have her own group of
super people she could control but the
team leaves a lot to be desired while
it's kind of accurate to the comics the
film doesn't really make the reasons for
their roster clear villains like Killer
Croc Diablo and Deadshot makes sense to
have around because their skills can be
pretty handy but what about Harley Quinn
and Captain Boomerang Harley Quinn has
been shown to be a clever tactician in
the comics but all of that's replaced
with tight shorts in the film last time
we checked hot pants weren't a
superpower Captain Boomerang is a
sociopathic bank robber who can throw
boomerangs which are the least effective
weapon of all time while we're on the
subject of the Captain Boomerang returns
after the team has as his near breakup
toward the middle of the film The Gang
decides to get back together and go face
off against enchantress it's fairly well
establish why everyone decides to stick
around for the big fight but then
Boomerang just randomly jumps in with
them as they do their heroic walk off
into battle unlike most of the other
team members Boomerang never really
showed any interest in being a team
player so why does he come back is it
because uh he's all into boomerangs and
they always come back
oh no it's coming back this way that
throwing stick stun of yours is
boomering and where does he keep getting
those beers maybe that's his real
superpower something wrong yank no it's
pretty big I
guess Star Trek Beyond is a fun
fast-paced space romp but just like any
great action movie these days it still
includes more than a few head scratchers
here's a look at some dumb things in
Star Trek Beyond everyone just ignored
random chance Creepy Bad Guy crawl is
looking for an alien artifact that was
chucked into space hundreds of years ago
so how convenient is it that Kurt
happens to randomly end up with it after
a totally unrelated diplomatic Mission
it's also handy for crawl that Kirk kept
it on board his ship instead of sending
it somewhere
safe that purle b f thank you oh and the
fact that he brings it to the closest
possible Outpost to crawl Bas is a
pretty lucky break as well you know
considering the endless vastness of
space and all dangling plot thread when
everyone takes the Escape pods and heads
for crawl's Planet Scotty drops out late
and navigates his pod down to the
surface when he gets there he realizes
he's landed it on the edge of a very big
cliff and finds himself in a classic
Fast and Furious style action scene
where he has to run up the falling pod
and grab hold of a tiny ledge hanging
off the cliff then we we cut away and
the next time we see Scotty he's safely
wandering around the planet at the
bottom of the cliff so how did he get
off the cliff Scotty is known for his
big brain but not for his epic mountain
climbing skills unless he jury riged the
jetpack we'd expect the scene to him
with him just falling to his death those
darn drones so craw's whole thing to get
this artifact is to create a deadly biow
weapon but since crawl already has a
seemingly Unstoppable drone Army capable
of taking out starfleet's most advanced
ships why not just attack with that
style points plus we find out those
drones are based on some ancient mining
Tech left on the planet so how did crawl
turn a bunch of mining robots into the
universe's most dangerous Fleet does
that mean some jerky super villain will
just be able to weaponize all the drones
we have flying around here on Earth this
amazing Innovation then lowers itself
slowly to the ground drops off the
package and flies straight back up to
altitude did we just figure out the real
reason that Amazon's Jeff Bezos made a
cameo in the
movie
cheers total recrawl Jayla has
conveniently been living in the USS
Franklin for years and has used a fancy
bit of cloaking Tech to keep the ship
hidden from crawl and his minions but
once crawl is revealed to be the
long-lost captain of the Franklin it
begs the question how did he not already
know where his ship landed space Amnesia
a long night of drinking space beers
yeah it's probably the space beers
that's usually
it beasty Bikes let's make some
noise okay so no one's going to dispute
that this was probably one of the most
fun scenes in the movie and yes we love
the Beasty Boys too but even though it's
been a running gag since 2009 Star Trek
reboot the fact that the Beasty Boys are
still supposedly relevant 3 centuries
from now is actually pretty silly don't
agree here's a quick quiz name a pop
star from the
1760s while you're Googling that we also
have to ask about the motorcycle that
plays a pivotal role in the finale why
is there an ancient motorcycle on the
USS Franklin and how is it still working
after all this time between the bike and
the beasy boys it seems like director
Justin Lynn really just wanted to make a
cool' 80s biker flick
instead Ura spidey sense we get a peak
of the USS Frank 's old crew footage
Midway through the film though Kirk and
everyone else turns away before Idris
Ela appears in the frame but Aura
circles back to the footage late in the
film gets a look at the long-lost
captain and immediately deduces that the
captain is actually
[Music]
crawl it's
him but how he doesn't look anything
like that anymore does she have facial
recognition software along with the GPS
tracker and that necklace spot gave her
Lieutenant Aur wears a Vaya amulet which
I presented to her as a token of my
affection and respect you gave your
girlfriend radioactive jewelry the
emission is harmless doctor but its
unique signature makes it very easy to
identify you gave your girlfriend a
tracking
device that was not my intention or
maybe all that Vulcan radiation gave her
superpowers that let her see through
Hollywood
Prosthetics terrible security when crawl
makes his move and attacks Yorktown
pretty much the only people around to
help stop the baddy from unleashing his
virus are Kirk and the members of his
team along with of course Greg grumberg
but this is supposed to be a fully Mann
top-of-the-line space station so why are
there no actual security measures the
only time we see anyone at all is when
the Yorktown Mall Cops run right past
the bad guy like a bunch of well Mall
Cops good job the big questions a big
chunk of crawl's plan is built on the
fact that he's able to hack into
Starfleet and figure out where the
artifact is to Stage his attack on the
Enterprise so if he can contact
Starfleet why didn't he ever just like
call them for help isn't he like a few
hundred years old how does he even know
how to pull any of this off how is crawl
able to hack into Starfleet at all is he
a member of
anonymous Scotty wrote the script now
it's important when considering some of
the goofier aspects of Star Trek Beyond
to remember that Simon Peg co-wrote the
script that's probably why Scotty can
suddenly scale sheer Cliffs Finds a Hot
Space elf girlfriend right out of the
Hobbit and then somehow manages to get
the USS Franklin running again in a
matter of hours more than a century
after it crashed face first into a
planet knowing that Scotty is basically
a walking Dux Machina also explains how
he was able to teleport 20 people at a
time during the film's Epic escape
sequence just a few minutes earlier he
didn't trust it enough to beam out two
people at a time which is why bones
nearly got nabbed by crawl's thugs at
least I won't die
[Music]
alone well that's just typical but when
the plot needs it suddenly he's totally
cool with just transporting entire
football teams with no problems sure how
many people can the Franklin transport
at a time uh with a weit of modification
20 but I'm not sure how long it would
hold out oh and then there's the part
where they jump start the Franklin just
by flinging it off a mountain despite
the fact that we're told the Franklin
wasn't designed to even function in the
planet's atmosphere of course it's no
surprise that he struggled riding the
13th Star Trek film it's a fact sure as
day fall as night sure as eggs as eggs
sure as every odd-numbered Star Trek
movie
[Music]
H with a worldwide Hall of $2.7 billion
Avatar is literally the most successful
film ever made and it's actually pretty
good too well if the fans are to be
believed anyway Cameron's gorgeous and
vibrant world was something that people
just want to hang around in and when
they couldn't they got pretty bummed out
when I woke up this morning after
watching avatar for the first time
yesterday the world seemed gray it was
like my whole life everything I've done
and worked for lost its meaning slow
down though that doesn't mean Avatar was
perfect between all of those dazzling
special effects were a few dumb things
in Avatar that everyone just ignored
basic biology let's not even get into
the science of growing an alien hybrid
clone and taking control of it with your
emotions but what happens to humans
bodies while they're in those pods we're
told Jake spends a 16-hour stint in that
little box but how did he like use the
bathroom are they wearing high-tech
diapers or are they just following
Austin Po's pod
rules we don't see anyone hooked up to
anything in the box so are they just
holding it or is there a drain at the
bottom or something and to a larger
extent why not add a feeding tube
hamsters do it we can do it convenient
straws involve science that we've
already perfected for total idiots so
why can't we do this in the future Jake
loses weight and is constantly reminded
to eat when he comes out of the Pod they
can control alien hybrids with their
mind machines but they can't build in
stuff for basic bodily functions we
expect more from you future do your
homework Jake is recruited to relocate
to Pandora but he seems pretty much
clueless about everything in Pandora he
skipped over the extensive training
required to be part of the Avatar
program and just read the manual instead
how much lab training have you had I
disected frog once everyone knows you
don't skip the tutorial especially if
it's your real alien body on the line
yes Pandora is a beautiful new world but
Jake doesn't know his Avatar ass from
his Avatar elbow he messes with plants
that could be poisonous and he doesn't
know the first thing about the
indigenous animals that he's tasked with
protecting his team from which doesn't
stop him from shoving his ponytail into
one which is gross the film obviously
needs a character to serve as a way into
the story but the dude could have dug a
little deeper than Pandora's Wikipedia
page why use avatars at all the entire
concept of creating these alien avatars
doesn't seem like a way to build real
trust with an alien civilization the
na'vi are smart enough to understand
that humans are different than they are
so why do they think that making these
fake versions of the aliens will help
them connect haven't they seen Star Trek
disguising yourself as an alien rarely
turns out well and then you have to get
down with a nerdy alien and everything's
a mess now will you help me if you make
love to
me what also if you're really trying to
blend in you have to go native
so why the heck do they still wear human
clothes on their Avatar bodies if you're
going to all the trouble to build this
insanely expensive alien body you
probably shouldn't dress like a tourist
lost in Pandora we are asked to believe
that in the distant future science can
create alien avatars that can be
controlled through thought but it can't
track them what I got a a native doing
the funky chicken here he's blocking my
blade well keep going you these people
out learn that we don't stop they can
barely even ID their guys visually and
almost kill Jake with her bulldozzer
even today as the grunting neanderthals
that we are we can track just about
everything from our dogs to our cars so
what's up high-tech future when Jake is
separated from the team they have to
scour the woods to try and find him
tracking isn't that hard even without a
Global Network of satellites and
especially not a century into the future
we found Waldo we found Carmen San Diego
and we can find Jake and his fancy alien
body late to the game the na'vi have a
Fighting Chance during the big face off
at the end of the film because Jake
travels around Pandora and rallies the
different tribes to help fend off the
sky people it's too bad none of the
na'vi thought of this sooner the entire
na'vi culture is built around a respect
for nature but this is the first time
they've considered the idea of teaming
up to try to push these Sky people out
once and for all all it took was a
non-native hero to come in and fix all
the dumb na'vi problems or maybe getting
the na'vi to do their own version of the
Care Bear stair was really just a weak
plot contrivance the Giant Knife it made
for a cool bizarre moment when Colonel
Miles kic's robot pulled out his own
Giant Knife during a fight but the whole
thing is wildly impractical if you want
to add a bladed weapon to your giant
robot build it right into the arm robots
are made with all kinds of awesome
Contraptions and hidden doodads instead
the robot designers created a holster
for the knife and then relied on a robo
hand to hold it it which then drops it
even bb-8 had a lighter tucked away in
his guts and you know what as far as
movie knives go it wasn't even all that
impressive that's not a
knife that's a
knif in 2017 fans of creepy clown hij
Jinks rushed to the theater breaking box
office records in a rush to see the
remake of it adapted from the Stephen
King book of the same name the film was
met with wide Acclaim and hailed as a
new classic but just because something
is awesome doesn't mean it can't be kind
of stupid too despite its iconic scenes
killer writing and knockout performances
it has its share of moments that left us
scratching our heads Georgie who if you
know anyone who lost a sibling growing
up you're probably very aware that it's
a devastating blow that can tear apart
both families and communities except in
Dairy in Dairy you mostly shrug it off
and make fun of your friend's mom when
Georgie goes missing the only people who
seem torn up about it are Bill and his
dad probably his mom mom too her entire
contribution seems to be providing
incidental piano music for her youngest
child to get eaten by a clown too
everyone deals with tragedy in their own
way but none of the kids seem to do much
to process the fact that a little boy
straight up disappeared into the great
unknown detective Ben that Benjamin is a
heck of a dude he's got an eye for
detail and an inquisitive mind would you
believe he was the first person in all
of der's history to notice that there's
an inexplicable disaster every 27 years
how is it that in a town that's been
around for presumably about 260 years
the first person to notice this trend is
a board kid on summer break none of the
cops or teachers or historians in this
town has ever been thumbing through a
history of dairy and noticed the kids
get killed here on an alarmingly regular
basis congratulations kid you're this
universe's Batman librarian hubris we
find Ben in the library studying up on
possible past it encounters he's
learning that's good we want him in the
library there's only one person who
doesn't want him in the libr library and
that's the librarian isn't it summer
vacation I would think you'd be ready to
take a break from the books she kicks a
quietly stud child out of the library
you know like Librarians do was there
really a point in history when
Librarians were so secure in the idea
that libraries would be around forever
that they'd shoot inquisitive patrons
out the door if she's still working
today she probably looks back longingly
on the days when you could evict someone
from the library for something besides
trying to live in the
bathroom history class take a look at
Ben's bedroom it's got pictures and
newspaper clippings lining the walls and
well this how he got all of this
information home when he apparently
can't leave the library without getting
mugged as a mystery in itself but that
isn't the point who shows up in an
illustration you'd better believe it's
Pennywise in a print of the signing of
der's toown Charter but it showing up in
an old image means one of two things
either it is doing his usual routine of
projecting into places he shouldn't be
or else it was there at Town Hall in the
late 1700s and not only did nobody
mention or object to it but he just
barely warranted making it into the 18th
century equivalent of the group photo
how could you forget that face who
taught you murder as far as we know it
has one job eating kids that's its whole
deal it's been popping up every 27 years
to do just that so why is he so bad at
it how many kids does he kill two maybe
four depending on how you count the
children of Derry would have been in
more danger if a bad flu had hit the
town and what about the bullies that it
eliminated in a way it saved more lives
than he took by nipping those pieces of
work in the bud pick a lane Pennywise
there's the argument that it feeds on
children's fear two counterpoints first
in a much more literal sense he feeds on
children secondly in the book it refers
to causing fear as more of a way of
salting the meat which means this dude
is risking his life to season his steak
pretty fancy for a guy who spends his
time in the sewers speaking of diseases
of dairy let's discuss for a moment what
makes sewers so important they convey
human waste rainwater runoff and our ill
ated goldfish from cities to treatment
plants and Disposal Outlets they're more
or less the key thing that separates us
from apes but they're Rife with disease
and these kids are traing through them
like they're a McDonald's play place
sorry every one of these kids is getting
hepatitis Eddie brings this up when they
first start exploring the baren but you
know what sassiness doesn't protect you
from chera maybe we're projecting the
losers Club heads to Bill's Garage where
Bill has set up what's doomed to be the
second worst Ted talk about clowns of
all time they're flipping through slides
with the slide projector takes on a life
of its own until a series of photos of
Bill and Georgie's mom undergos a
nightmarish transformation mom straight
up turns into Pennywise and then nobody
unplugs the projector turn it
off Mike kicks the projector off the
table but still nobody turns it off
everybody in the room just screams and
wigs out failing to take their lives or
in fact the power cord into their own
hands Bin's got guts tough guy Ben walks
off an astonishing number of gut
injuries in this movie first the bullies
try to carve their names into him with a
switchblade which he escapes by tumbling
down a dirt hill and trouncing through
sewer runoff only to have his wounds
treated by children with drugstore
bandages then in the creepy house Ben
gets slashed in the belly by it which he
just sort of seems to ignore afterward
after that first Haunted Mansion
encounter he's just standing out the
street with 4ot long gashes in his
abdomen you could maybe see his appendix
if you squint it's worth pointing out
that during that whole scene Eddie's mom
is standing in front of Ben watching him
bleed from his torso and she thinks it's
more important to shame a 12-year-old
than it is to find him a doctor the
adults in this town are a mess Define
death in a lot of ways it isn't supposed
to make sense it's a piece of horror
fiction that deals in the Supernatural
but still there's one thing that really
truly doesn't make any sense
specifically how are those insanely
self-destructive bullies still alive all
we see them do in this movie is take
needless risks for two hours they drive
blindly down Alleyways at break neck
speed they make flamethrowers out of
cans of hairspray they dive head first
down steep hills covered in debris they
play with loaded guns they're the
definition of awful it shouldn't have
taken an extra dimensional demon to beat
these Jerks with their behavior every
one of them should have been a full
color in loving memory page in the
yearbook by their sophomore
year the Terminator has spawned multiple
sequels and prequels both in movie
theaters and on television but as good
as it is it's far from a perfect film to
learn how among other things a perfectly
logical thinking machine acts like a
keep watching for the dumb things
everyone ignored in The
Terminator since he's governed by a
ruthlessly calculating artificial
intelligence you might assume that the
Terminator would make purely logical
choices watch the movie though and one
of the first things you'll notice is
that his actions absolutely do not
reflect that for one thing he can't even
decide on how quiet he needs to keep his
time travel murder Mission as soon as he
arrives in the 80s for example the
Terminator makes an immediate effort to
get Era appropriate clothing that will
allow him to blend into 1984 or at least
blend in as much as an insanely jacked
Austrian bodybuilder can anyway hey I
think this guy's a couple cans short of
a six-pack you're
close give them to me now and yet
throughout the movie he draws plenty of
attention to himself and never seems to
care he steals a pile of guns from a gun
shop and murders the owner with a
shotgun this is the loudest possible way
he could do it which will almost
certainly draw the attention of the
police even in what we see in the movie
up to that point it's obvious that he
could totally kill the owner with his
bare hands flip the closed sign over and
lock the door behind him giving him at
least a few hours before anyone thinks
to call the authorities shortly
afterward he kills the first Sarah
Connor he finds in the phone book he
bothers to knock on the door and ask her
name then smashes the door open and
shoots her six times in a quiet
residential neighborhood as with the gun
shop he could have done it all much more
quietly and if he's not going to be
quiet why bother knocking on the door
and asking her name manners every now
and then you come across a character in
a movie who is so annoying and stupid
that you can't help but despise them as
a viewer while the comparatively
intelligent protagonist doesn't seem to
thoroughly hate them as much as they
should such is the case of Nancy the
waitress who ranks among the most
frustrating characters in the history of
film Sarah Connor is working at a diner
when we meet her and not only is her
Section filled with increasingly irate
customers a young boy takes the
opportunity to drop a lump of ice cream
in her apron that's when Nancy comes up
behind her and says that nobody's going
to Care in a 100 years which is the kind
of contrived Zinger that she would only
say if she knew she was in movie where
time traveling robots exterminated human
civilization in the next Century then
she just bailes without even bothering
to help her friend and cooworker clean
up the mess that might not seem that bad
but don't worry Nancy goes completely
off the rails a few minutes later after
the Terminator kills another woman named
Sarah Connor and makes the news Nancy
grabs Sarah and pulls her into the break
room to watch the report giving her the
most insane reason ever spoken you're
not going to believe this sit down you
are going to love this why would anyone
love hearing about how someone with
their name was violently murdered what's
wrong with you Nancy she's just lucky
she didn't say this stuff to the super
buff T2 Sarah Connor who would have
absolutely punched her lights out from
what Kyle ree says he didn't have a lot
of time to prepare for his trip into the
Past after he's arrested Reese tells the
police psych colleges that John Connor's
forces found a time machine in a lab
complex they captured ree was sent to
the 20th century and the lab complex was
destroyed even if they were hustling to
get to the P though which seems like a
weird concern when you have a time
machine shouldn't John Connor have taken
a couple of minutes to remind Reese that
it was probably going to be tough to
protect his mom if she thought he was
completely insane the first conversation
that two characters have after ree
storms into a nightclub blasting at a
gun tooning as salant which to put it
mildly is a pretty stressful situation
involves Reese overloading Sarah with a
flood of ridiculously precise
information about the Terminator it's
like he's reading the instruction manual
going on about its micro processor
controlled hyper alloy combat chassis
that's not information that Sarah would
care about or even stand in the best of
times let alone when it's being shouted
at her by a sweaty man with a shotgun
her initial reaction once Reese pulls
into a parking garage Sarah
understandably tries to escape fighting
Reese's hand hard enough to draw blood
can you blame her Reese is from o Bleak
apocalyptic future filled with Killer
Robots so the world of 1984 is probably
as weird to him as he is to Sarah but
someone definitely should have given him
some tips on how to start up a
conversation with another human being
and even if they didn't reys is a smart
guy starting off slow and then easing
Sarah Connor into the world of the hyper
alloy combat chassis would seem like a
pretty obvious
strategy as you may already know the
Terminator is pretty difficult to
destroy it doesn't feel pity or remorse
or fear and it absolutely will not stop
ever for the most part the best Kyle ree
can do is slow the Terminator down but
as the film progresses the cyborg shows
more and more signs of battle damage
eventually he's completely stripped of
All Flesh revealing his mechanical
interior the first casualties of the
terminator's outward human disguise are
his eyebrows which are burned off in an
explosion after he attacks Sarah and
Reese in a nightclub it makes sense that
he'd lose them too since they'd
naturally be singed off with that kind
of fire what doesn't make sense is that
the eyebrows are all the Terminator
loses in that fight the same exploding
gas tank that engulfs his entire body
and completely erases his eyebrows has
done absolutely nothing to the hair on
his head nor do his clothes seem at all
damaged by the flames you could maybe
ride off the clothes by assuming that
the punk the Terminator stole his outfit
from invested in a fireproof wardrobe
for some unexplained reason but for the
hair there's no excuse even stranger the
scene happens right before ree has a
conversation with Sarah where he
explicitly tells her that this model of
Terminator has fully organic skin and
hair covering up its metal skeleton if
those eyebrows are going Arnold's
perfect qua should be dust too after
showing up in 1984 and eventually
finding a pair of pants ree tries to
explain the future to Sarah as best he
can he covers the the emergence of
Skynet and the resulting nuclear
Holocaust the rise of the Terminators
and their Grim plans for Humanity he
explains it all but the audience is left
with a mystery how does Reese or John
Connor or anyone else in the future even
know about Skynet or how their world
came under the literal Iron Fist of the
machines obviously the survivors would
know that the machines were in charge
but when you think about it it isn't
quite so obvious to figure out how the
human resistance ever learned about the
creation of Skynet from what Reese tells
us Skynet decided the fate of the human
race in a millisecond all of that
presumably took place within the ai's
processors with the human race left
scattered and without access to
technology or the power to make that
technology work how could anyone be able
to access the data necessary to
determine how the world went sideways
they don't necessarily need to know in
order to fight back but they certainly
need a way to discover it if they're
going to go back in time and explain it
to Sarah Connor the big twist of the
Terminator is of course that it's all
one big loop after traveling back in
time at the request of John Connor reent
Sarah get it on and in the process they
conceived that same John Connor Humanity
savior who wouldn't exist if it wasn't
for the mission that he ordered that's
Destiny baby even if you can get your
head around all the time travel H Jinks
though the fact that their brief affair
even happens is just a little weird if
not majorly weird while they're on the
run from the Terminator ree ends up
confessing to Sarah that her unborn son
gave him a picture of her which he kept
and obsessed over for years he tells her
that he fell in love with her because of
that photo without ever meeting her or
talking to her
it's more than just a little creepy
Sarah is obviously still reeling from
being hunted by a killer cyborg from the
future not to mention being on the run
from the authorities and having her
roommate murdered and yet even with all
that learning that this sweaty weirdo
became obsessed with her thanks to a
photograph that she hasn't even taken
yet is the weirdest thing that's
happened to her why doesn't she freak
out even more or maybe she's into it
we're not judging it just seems like
most first dates that start off with I'm
from the future are already going to be
in enough Jeopardy without adding and I
used used to just stare at your picture
for hours on end when he's first being
interviewed by the condescending police
psychologist ree says that things in the
future are actually starting to look up
for the few remaining humans under the
leadership of John Connor they had won
the battle against Skynet and smashed
the machine's defense grid sending the
Terminator back in time was a last ditch
effort on the machines part made out of
desperation by this elaborate scheme
with the Terminator it had no choice
their defense grid was smashed we'd won
that's good news for Humanity but from
what little we see of the future it's
kind of hard to believe in both scenes
we see of the future first with Reese
and his fellow soldiers being defeated
by a flying machine and then with a
Terminator infiltrating an underground
bunker and killing almost everyone in
sight the human seem absolutely hopeless
maybe that's just how things are on the
front but all of those piles of skulls
aren't exactly cheery especially since
ree has to throw everything he can at
the Terminator to barely slow it down
and eventually dies in the process so
how how exactly does John Connor manage
to defeat this Unstoppable
self-replicating enemy the humans have
barely any resources and we see them
hunt rats for food the fact that they
have any weapon tree at all seems like
at least a minor miracle it's hard to
understand how they could possibly win
no matter how good Jon is at looking
through
binoculars the Terminator ends with
Sarah Connor in Mexico on her way to
becoming the hard and badass we find in
1991's Terminator 2 Judgment Day she's
got a new dog with her presumably to
detect any other Terminators who might
travel through time and she's recording
a sort of journal on tape as she travels
musing on the question of whether or not
she will tell her unborn son that Kyle
ree was his father of all the things she
could be telling someone anyone about
the future is the identity of Jon's
father really her biggest concern a time
traveling fraternity test might make a
great episode for Mory Povich once his
show starts up in 1991 but come on Sarah
let's get our priorities straight here
of course that's not to suggest Sarah
should be yelling from the highest
mountain that everyone's going to die
soon thanks to Killer Robots as we we
see in Terminator 2 that's exactly the
sort of thing that lands her in a mental
institution it's just that in terms of
what she should reveal about the future
she's rating do I tell my son about his
dad over do I tell people they should
start building robot proof
shelters yes Indiana Jones is among the
most beloved of film franchises but that
doesn't mean the movies are without
their flaws we've all rolled our eyes at
the scene where Indie survives a nuclear
bomb by hiding in a refrigerator but
here's a rundown of some other less
obvious but still pretty dumb things
things that the Indiana Jones movies ask
its viewers to ignore when Raiders of
the L AR opens Indiana Jones is unfaced
by his colleague stories about ancient
mystical powers that could destroy
everyone seeking the Ark of the Covenant
by the end of the movie Once he's
experienced a bunch of ghosts with the
power to melt Nazis faces off he's
forced to accept that there are powers
in the world well beyond his
understanding he even ends a movie by
warning the government agents that they
don't know what they're dealing
with you don't look very happy fools
bureaucratic they don't know what
they've got there Great Character Arc
right here's a problem while it came out
3 years after Raiders Temple of Doom is
actually a prequel that takes place a
year earlier in that movie Indie saw a
man's heart magically ripped from his
chest while still beating and personally
turned magic Stones White H by invoking
the name of Shiva despite bearing
witness to all that Indiana Jones is
still a skeptic in the Last Crusade he's
very quick to dismiss stories about King
Arthur and the hood Grail as bedtime
stories he's even still hanging on to
those doubts when Crystal Skull rolls
around it's one thing to try and ensure
your character can be relatable and
realistic when he's dealing with ancient
Fantastical Mysteries but for Indie to
Simply ignore some of the most exciting
perplexing and Incredibly real moments
of his life is just silly after
thrilling chases a couple of failed
rescue attempts and outsmarting the bad
guys at every turn throughout Raiders of
the last dark Indiana Jones and Marian
Ravenwood are captured and forced to
witness a hellish moment when the bad
guys open the the ark as the power of
the Ark is Unleashed Indie tells Marian
that they can't look at it no matter
what happens he's right too in the midst
of a cury of nais being burned alive by
the wrath of God the good guys are
spared from its wrath so how in the
world did Indie know not to look at the
ark earlier in the film it's mentioned
that the ark was hidden away due to its
immense power being too much for mankind
to handle but the cheat code of Just
closing one's eyes came kind of out of
nowhere also we're not complaining but
it does seem a little weird that nobody
else figured out that they shouldn't
look at the blinding light that was
melting everyone as it turns out Indie
was warned about this in a scene that
was cut from the final version of the
movie that might be a good way for Indie
to know but the audience sure doesn't it
might seem like we're picking on Raiders
but in a movie that's otherwise perfect
the few floors are really easy to spot
take for instance ind's trip on a Nazi
submarine the key word there is on not
in with the help of a friendly sea
captain Indie stealths his way into a
uboat to rescue Maran and defeat belloc
jumping a top it just before it goes
underwater the film then cuts to an
island where the villains plann to open
the Ark of the Covenant so how did our
soaking wet Indie survive the trip
obviously he couldn't just cling to the
Periscope and hold his breath for
hundreds of miles but from what we've
seen in the movie and even a deleted
scene that's exactly what happened it's
just a good thing nobody ever bothered
to lower the Periscope for the entire
trip or else would have to deal with the
explanation that Indie was secretly the
Lost king of Atlantis all this time when
Temple of Doom opens Indiana Jones is
accompanied by a young child named one
Lee who Jones refers to a Short Round
it's later revealed that the young
Chinese boy from Shanghai got busted
trying to pick the archaeologist pocket
and they eventually became friends you
make me poor no fun while opinions are
split about Short Round it's undeniable
that he provided some comic relief and
drove the getawayer Bal stunts as daring
as his mentor and even broke Indie from
a magic mind control trance by the end
of the film they both returned to the
small Indian village as triumphant
Heroes after that who knows the third
movie opens with absolutely no mention
of Short Round there's not even a
whisper of him nor is he mentioned in
Raiders of the Lost AR which came after
Temple of Doom chronologically Short
Round is just gone after the credits
role romantic Partners like Willie come
and go for a rugged and handsome
Bachelor like Jones the young child that
he took under his wing and brought
thousands of miles from his home on
numerous death defying Adventures you
think that at least they in touch we
might even be willing to forgive some of
Crystal skull's more egregious sins if
IND the successor turned out to be kii
Kuan instead of shy buff there's a lot
to be upset about in Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull but the most important
might just be that it shifts the genre
of the franchise in a way that just
doesn't work there's nothing wrong with
a good science fiction story if that's
what you want to call this movie but for
it to come in the fourth installment of
a franchise rooted in pulpy Fantastical
Adventure after a nearly 20-year Gap
just feels jarring and
unnecessary I've got a bad feeling about
this the movie ends with Jones and his
cohorts finding a collection of alien
skeletons with one missing head after
returning the infamous Crystal skull the
aliens come to life and vacate Earth in
a flying sorcerer Indiana Jones is a guy
who frequently comes across the unknown
in his Pursuits of ancient and
mysterious artifacts but Roswell aliens
are a very different kind of mysterious
even if and especially if they show up
20 years after he was dealing with
Biblical goblets they feel out of place
in Indy's world of historical Legends
and Supernatural Treasures in short
never switch shamra in the fourth movie
of a
series like was pretty fast
if you don't stop and look around once
in a while you could miss it well Ferris
bu's day off moves pretty fast too
perhaps everyone has seen it so many
times that they didn't even stop and
look around and realize that there are a
lot of baffling events in the movie one
of Ferris earliest schemes involves
securing a car for the day Ferris tells
us I asked for a car I got a computer as
a way of explaining why he doesn't have
wheels of his own the problem is that
his computer is one of the many
expensive toys that fill his bedroom in
addition to a computer cool enough to be
connected to the web in the mid 80s
Ferris room is also stuffed with a slick
sound system and even a synthesizer he
puts to particularly good
use throw in a classic electric guitar
and he's got quite a bit of money laying
around sell your stuff berer after
fooling his parents with a fake illness
Ferris next big task is convincing his
best friend Cameron fry to join him on
his day off ironically Cameron is
already out of school for the day
homesick in bed for real Ferris doesn't
believe Cameron noting his hypochondriac
Tendencies but Cameron does seem to be
quite ill so much so that he barely
feels like moving somehow Ferris is able
to Rouse him and bring him along on the
trip and just like that Cameron is fine
he goes from lying in bed to hanging out
at a Chicago Cubs game not once during
the day do we see Cameron becoming dizzy
trying to nap or knocking back some
Dayquil he was either faking it or he
was was miraculously cured Ferris
invites Cameron along in part because he
needs a car they could just use Camerons
but Ferris is too greedy for that he
wants to spend the day out on the town
in style and has his heart set on
stealing Cameron's father's car a
limited edition 1961 Ferrari convertible
it's a pretty sweet ride and so valuable
that Cameron's dad doesn't even drive it
he just rubs it with a diaper despite
the car's value though there's little to
no security for it it's just sitting
there without any protection in the
garage which Cameron and Ferris can just
walk into it's almost as if Mr Fry wants
it to get stolen Ferris covers his
tracks at his house with a dummy a
complex pulley system and a tape playing
snoring Sounds by comparison his scheme
to get his girlfriend Sloan Peterson out
of school for the day is surprisingly
low Tech it starts with a phone call
from Cameron posing as Sloan's father
claiming her grandmother died Ferris and
Cameron then head to the school to grab
Sloan when Ferris arrives he has to
disguise himself as her father by
wearing an an oversized trench coat and
old-fashioned hat somehow dean of
students Mr Rooney is fooled by the lazy
ruse even after Ferris and Sloan share a
long wet kiss one of the first things
Ferris does on his day off is take
Cameron and Sloan to an extremely fancy
restaurant he doesn't have a reservation
so he steals someone else's from the
restaurant's list for this scheme he
chooses to pose as Abe Fran The Sausage
King of Chicago the restaurant's host is
of course very skeptical of Ferris claim
Ferris Works around him by having Sloan
call the restaurant and describe him as
Fran somehow it works and the Babyface
teen who is obviously not a meat magnate
gets his table one of the most famous
scenes in Ferris bu's day off is the
parade sequence but there's a lot about
the scene that's hard to understand it's
a big cultural event that shuts down
several downtown city blocks but it's
somehow held in the middle of a weekday
the heart of the scene is a bit baffling
too huge parades are highly secured but
this one just lets some random teen up
onto a float to lipsync to an oldway
Newton song and why does the float have
a microphone anyway it's not hooked up
to any kind of sound system this all
leads to a synchronized dance number set
to Twist and Shout it's a little more
realistic that Ferris would know that
song but it's not realistic at all that
a bunch of people have put together
dance routines to go along with this
otherwise completely spontaneous
performance Ferris plans his day off so
it's packed with extremely fun
activities he and his friends go to the
Sears Tower the Art Institute of Chicago
a fancy lunch a Chicago Cubs game and
even a parade one problem with packing
all that into one day is that there's no
way Ferris Cameron and Sloan could fit
it all in with the limited time they've
got it's midm morning by the time Ferris
convinces Cameron to come with him then
he has to jailbreak Sloan from school
and then drive into the city once
they're in the city they have to leave
the car in a garage factoring in travel
time between activities plus setbacks
like traffic there's no way Ferris is
getting back to the suburbs before his
parents the villain of the film is dean
of students Ed Rooney and he both hates
and OB esses over Ferris buer the thing
is that Rooney actually has a good
reason noting that Ferris he gives good
kids bad ideas it's Rooney's job to keep
the student body in line and in class
something Ferris doesn't help with he
has so many absences that it's a problem
Rooney knows this and even sees the
evidence of Ferris covering his tracks
by hacking school records so Rooney
spends the movie tracking buer to prove
the kid isn't really sick he goes
through a lot of nonsense to catch ber
in the act of skipping school which
means he's really just a guy trying to
do his
job Stanley Kubrick's The Shining is a
masterpiece as a result some details in
the film that seem out of place serve to
illustrate the supernatural forces at
work in the Overlook other
inconsistencies can't be dismissed so
easily here are a few dumb things in The
Shining that we just can't
ignore the creepy sets and confusing
layout of the Overlook Hotel are a
central part of the plot of The Shining
the Halls are a labyrinth and the
feeling of being lost and isolated with
no idea what's around the next corner is
a key part of what makes everything so
scary this mysterious feeling is
mirrored by the Hedge maze outside and
while it's only fitting that the climax
of the film takes place there the
location is established very early on
just not as early as it should have been
the opening scene of the film gives the
audience an aerial view of the Overlook
and the grounds including the hotel
itself the surrounding forests and the
mountains in the distance the feeling of
isolation is there reinforcing the idea
that this is the kind of place where no
one can hear you scream for help
eagle-eyed viewers will notice that
there's something missing though the
Hedge maze is supposed to be right next
to the hotel just a short walk away from
the entrance but in the shot that
establishes our setting it's nowhere to
be found despite the fact that it's
enormous and would definitely be visible
from the sky maybe it just sprung up as
a product of Jack's increasing Madness
or maybe the curse at the heart of the
Overlook just really likes
metaphors before officially accepting
the caretaker job Jack goes back to the
Overlook for an interview at first it's
pretty standard with Mr Olman the
manager telling him all about the job
and his potential responsibilities he
warns him about just how far away from
civilization he'll really be explaining
there's basically nothing to do outside
of the hotel and that he and his family
will be alone he then drops what might
be the biggest red flag that any job
interview has ever had while discussing
how the previous caretaker lost the
job killed his family with an
axe man also mentions in passing that
although they're in Colorado there's no
skiing in the area clearly this is just
to reinforce the idea that there's no
quick way off the mountain but it's
contradicted by the film itself it's
tough to spot but in those aerial shots
at the beginning of the film you can see
a ski lift going up the side of a
mountain not far from the
hotel before the events of the film take
place jack Torrance came home drunk one
night and dislocated Danny's shoulder he
then promised that he wouldn't touch
alcohol ever again Wendy tells dany's
doctor about the incident saying that
it's been 5 months since Danny's injury
and so far Jack has stayed true to his
word perhaps unsurprisingly however Jack
later makes a comment that doesn't match
up with Wendy's
timeline I didn't hurt him once okay
when he's sitting at the bar in the Gold
Room and griping to the bartender Lloyd
about what happened he says that it all
went down 3 years ago there are a couple
of possible explanations for this the
most obvious is that it's just a minor
mistake in the script which makes sense
given how many drafts The Shining went
through before it was filmed with kubric
behind the camera though there's also a
chance that this was totally intentional
maybe Jack is disconnecting from time as
the isolation of the Overlook drives in
Matt maybe he's remembering an incident
from Grady's life not his own or maybe
in the most disturbing possibility that
incident a few months ago wasn't the
only time that Jack hurt Dany and he
doesn't even remember the more recent
abuse when Jack visits the Gold Room and
meets Lloyd the bartender we're not sure
if Lloyd is a ghost or a projection of
Jack's Twisted mind regardless Jack
strikes up a conversation with him and
orders himself a bourbon on the Rocks he
drinks throughout his rant about how
Wendy won't forgive him for his abuse of
Dany and when Wendy actually arrives in
the Gold Room crying about a mysterious
woman who tried to strangle Dany Lloyd
suddenly disappears along with all of
the Li and Decor behind the bar it's a
genuinely unsettling scene but either
someone in the props Department got a
little mixed up or Lloyd isn't actually
the best bartender from timbuk 2 to
Portland Maine or Portland Oregon
instead of the bourbon he asked for
Lloyd pours Jack a drink from a bottle
of Jack Daniels old number seven which
isn't quite what he asked for while Jack
Daniels is legally classified as
straight bourbon The Distillery never
markets it or refers to it as anything
but whiskey Lloyd's technically correct
but a hard Drinker like Jack Torrance
would definitely know the difference
between a Tennessee Whiskey and a
Kentucky bourbon even in
Colorado as the torren family drives to
the Overlook we see that they're
traveling in a small yellow Volkswagen
Beetle the shots from inside the car
revealed that while it's fairly cramped
space there's at least enough room for
Dany to move around later in the lobby
of the Overlook however Jack gestures to
the family's huge pile of luggage
sitting by the door Jack Wendy and Danny
are staying at the Overlook for months
and there won't be anywhere for them to
go shopping so they definitely need all
their clothes if they were really making
that journey in a VW Beetle though
there's no way they could have crammed
their entire wardrobe in the car and
still had room to breathe even with the
creepy space bending geography of the
Overlook there's only so much that a
Volkswagen can hold unless they also
bought their car from an ancient cursed
burial
ground though Halloween is renowned
among horror hounds the film is not
without its flaws Oddities and strange
leaps of logic none of these examples
can diminish the film's overall Legacy
but let's not pretend there aren't some
dumb things everyone ignores about John
Carpenters Halloween major horror films
of the 1970s like carrye and Last House
on the Left tended to cast 20-some on
the roles of teens in this respect
Halloween is no different but that
doesn't make the casting any less
distracting with the exception of jam
Lee Curtis who was 19 at the time
Halloween was released the actors who
played the teenagers were all well into
their 20s PJ Souls the actress who plays
Lor's cheerleader friend Linda was 28
years old similarly Lor's other friend
Annie was portrayed by 29-year-old Nancy
kais when all three girls are together
on screen it's incredibly awkward to
watch two grown women pretend to be high
school girls when paired with Curtis who
is noticeably younger than the other two
actresses the glaring age differences
are impossible to ignore I forgot my
chemistry book so who cares I always
forget my chemistry book and my math
book and my English book after Michael
breaks out of Smith's Grove sanitarium
at the beginning of the film Dr Lumis
rightfully fears what Michael will do
with his new found Freedom he takes his
concern to the police but is promptly
brushed off leaving him to hunt Michael
on his own well it was your patient
doctor precautions weren't strong enough
you should have told somebody I told
everybody suspecting Michael will return
to his childhood home Lumis makes his
way to henfield on his way he stops at a
pay phone and by pure circumstance
stumbles onto an abandoned car while the
camera pans to show the audience the
driver's body lying nearby Lumis is not
privy to the murder nevertheless the
good doctor somehow surmises that the
abandoned car in a stray matchbook a
solid proof that Michael Myers was there
what's so bizarre about this scene isn't
just the unlikely circumstances or Lumis
is apparent six sense but the fact that
he doesn't appear to report the crime at
all if Lumis is genuinely concerned
about what he found why wouldn't he call
the police if he had taken even a minute
to look around and not run off after
finding a random matchbook on the ground
he would have seen seen the dead body
and it would have likely forced the
police to cooperate while we don't know
much about the specific events that
triggered lumus and men's spere of
Michael it's safe to say the doctor
knows far more about the Killer's
violent tendencies than anyone else
after breaking out of confinement
stealing a car assaulting a woman and
killing an innocent man you'd think
anyone hunting Michael would at least be
cautious surprisingly the hunt for
Michael is incredibly lowkey Lumis seeks
out the help of haddenfield Sheriff Lee
braget and the two hunt Michael Al at
some point the sheriff suggests a
full-blown Manhunt but Lumis tosses the
idea aside for fear of causing a panic
if you do that they'll see him in every
street corner they'll look for him in
every house just tell your men to keep
their mouth shut and their eyes open
meanwhile Michael is walking around
killing teenagers and terrorizing Lori
it seems hypocritical from Lumis of all
people to prefer discretion over action
at the beginning of the film he was
Desperately Seeking police help but when
he finally gets it he turns the offer
down if a false search was organized
maybe Lor's friends wouldn't have been
butchered when Annie and Lori stumble
onto a recently robbed hardware store
an's father tells him that someone has
stolen a Halloween mask some knives and
rope the robbery must have just happened
as the alarm is blaring in the
background and a group of police
officers are actively surveying the
scene what happened oh uh somebody broke
into the hardware store probably kids
given the context the film is hinting
that Michael is the one who stole the
mask and the murder tours in theory that
makes sense but given the fact that the
girls had already encountered a MK
Michael far before the robbery
supposedly occurred he couldn't have
stolen the mask the first time we see
Michael after he escapes from Smith's
Grove is when he waits outside of Lor's
School clearly already wearing the mask
hours later when Lori walks home with
her friends the group encounters Michael
twice and right before Lori goes out
with Annie she spots him again outside
of her window all of these occurrences
happen before Michael supposedly robs
the store and yet in all of them he's
wearing the mask unless he robbed
another store and took another identical
mask for good measure this timeline just
doesn't add up though it's
understandable that Lori would make some
mistakes in a life or death situation
it's less acceptable that she would make
the same mistake three times when
Michael surprises Lori from inside the
Doyal house she reflexively stabs the
killer with a knitting needle Michael
falls to the ground seemingly defeated
in typical horror fashion however he is
very much alive and pursues Lori again
shortly after again Lori attacks Michael
jabbing him in the eye with a coat
hanger and stabbing him with a knife
Michael is down once more but instead of
checking to see if he's done for good
Lori makes the same mistake as before
and just assumes he's dead not ready to
call it quits Michael gets right back up
this time Lumis takes the offensive and
shoots him causing Michael to fall off
of the balcony despite Lori failing to
kill Michael twice before she and Lumis
decide it's better to have a
conversation rather than check to make
sure the fall or The Gunshot
successfully killed Michael what's the
Boogey me
as a matter of fact it was by the time
anyone bothers to look he's long gone if
Lumis or Lori had cared enough to check
Michael's pulse they wouldn't have to
worry about him continuing his killing
spre then again how else would he have
had so many Halloween sequels being a
lowbudget independent film created in a
short period Halloween naturally
couldn't avoid its fair share of little
mistakes ranging from continuity errors
to production Goose that eagley viewers
may be able to catch for example a cre
member is reflected in the foam Booth
glass right before Lumis discovers the
driver Michael killed on his way to
haddenfield though it can be a bit hard
to notice you can see Linda stumble as
she and Bob head upstairs in the Wallace
house apparently PJ Souls didn't just
lose her footing the actress tripped
over a dolly truck and when Annie is
teasing Lori about Michael in front of
the hedges a puff of smoke is briefly
caught on camera according to John
Carpenter the smoke came from his own
cigarette did you even know that Kate
Winslet was in avatar The Way of water
did cic and spider's relationship feel
forced here's the dumbest things that
happened in the Avatar
sequel Avatar the way of water is stuck
in a strange limbo it's both a sequel
picking up where Avatar left off in a
literal sense but also clearly made with
a nostalgic Zeal to remind people of the
original think of the way the Jurassic
World movies feel more like Jurassic
Park theme park rides than actual
extensions of a coherent Story the
dumbest thing in the way of water that
we just have to live with is how it
shoehorns new roles for soury Weaver and
Steven Lang into the story even though
both of their characters died in the
first movie Weaver's new character Kiri
a child mysteriously born of the Avatar
of her original character Dr Grace
Augustine at least has some strange
Messianic qualities that are unique but
asking us to just roll with Lang's
psychotic Colonel quich being reborn as
a recombinant form of Avatar is a bit
much it Recons Avatar in the sense that
the technology to create a digital copy
of a human consciousness apparently
existed at the time and quich and his
team backed themselves up before the
final showdown so essentially like the
ill- fated ending of lust the way of
water is asking us to invest in a world
where death has no meaning where Grace
Augustin and the other scientists also
backed up that would certainly explain
why her Avatar is just hanging around in
her a tank for no discernable purpose
the biggest criticism of the first
avatar is that Jake Sully is a classic
white savior
it's toned deaf that way that a complete
stranger to the na'vi way of life ends
up uniting the tribes and being chosen
as torak Maro you'd think years later in
the way of water since shus integrated
more fully and had half na'vi children
with ntii that this would be less of a
prevalent theme but it seems Kiri has
been added to the story as a second
white Savior for the price of one though
raised as na'vi she's essentially a sort
of reincarnated version of Grace
Augustine the other most benevolent
white person from the first movie movie
Kiri clearly has some chosen one type
Powers Brewing as she commutes with
nature and can hear the heartbeat of AA
the all mother not to mention the way of
water goes the same route to Star Wars
The Phantom Menace In introducing the
idea of Immaculate Conception with a
couple of casual off-hand remarks it's
apparently a total mystery how Grace
Augustine's K avvatar gave birth to a
child although the movie pulls at a very
disturbing thread a couple of times as
Kiri and other characters wonder who are
might
be there is something really interesting
going on in there
biologically I would die to get
samples few sins of the original Avatar
are as unforgivable as unobtanium the
precious mineral that humans were on
Pandora to harvest fortunately no one
utters that ridiculous word in the way
of water although the reappearance of
humanity is abruptly handled we do learn
early on that they have a much more
straightforward and Urgent reason to
return to to Pandora than getting rich
that is Earth is dying and Pandora is to
be entirely colonized as Humanity's new
home this creates a compelling Global
threat to all of the na'vi Clans that's
not even based on a bad pun but fully
2/3 of the way through the way of water
we learn there an entirely brand new
magical substance that humanity is after
on Pandora this a serum harvested from
the brains of giant sensient whike
creatures called tolken this enzyme
called amorites apparently stops the
aging process entirely Inhumans so the
hunting of tolens becomes another lazy
obvious allegory for the awful
colonizers not to respect sacred na'vi
Traditions since the Met kayena bomb
with the tolken and are heartbroken at
their L the humans of course Harvest
just about a 2 L soda bottles worth of
Amite from a Tolen the size of a
battleship and leave the rest to rot
were you even aware that the great Kate
Winslet is in this movie She provides
the voice of ronal the wife of the meay
in's leader and mostly glares
disapprovingly at Jake and family for
endangering her tribe the way of water
introduces many new characters but not a
single one has the star power of Winsley
an Oscar winner and one of the greatest
actresses of her generation so it's a
bit dumb when you realize that like the
majority of characters in this
overstuffed movie she didn't have time
for any sort of character Arc or subplot
of her own while it's likely she has a
bigger role to play in future
installments it doesn't make her bit
part in the way of water any of a missed
opportunity other than mourning her soul
sister tolan's death and being very
justifiably angry at the sulles for
bringing destruction with them out to
the islands ronal barely registers this
is why Kate Winslet had to hold her
breath under water for more than 7
Minutes yes that's true probably the
most Preposterous running thread in
avatar The Way of water is the
relationship between the rec combinant
Colonel quic and his long lost son
spider the kid is the most prominent
fully human character left in the story
having been left on Pandora as a small
child and raised with the na'vi the way
of Walter wants us to buy into big plot
points pivoting on the burgeoning
emotional bonds between this child of
Two Worlds and the lab grown Avatar of
his deceased father the problem with
this is that quich in either human or
Avatar form is by far the most
one-dimensional character in either
movie he's nothing but a murderer
Soldier and he outright tells spider
that since he's technically a form of
Clone he's not actually his father
anyway sure quich and spider may have a
few bonding moments while the latter was
being held hostage but it really didn't
go far enough then seemingly out of
nowhere quit is suddenly concerned about
spider when a tyi threatens his life in
late standoff spider then saves qu's
life which doesn't feel earned at all it
also doesn't even really matter because
presumably the humans could just keep
growing new qu recombinant and
redownloading his Consciousness anyway
James Cameron has an incredibly
successful career career so perhaps he's
earned a little bit of self-referential
leeway but we have to bring into
question the sequence near the end of
the way of water where star crust
crushes low Arch and reyer attempt to
survive by clambering around the outside
of an overturned ship these moments are
pretty shamelessly close to the Beats
from Cameron's Titanic to the point that
it takes you out of the movie a little
bit it's already a bit mud to ask us to
just roll with their romance which
lazily recreates the same beats as Jake
and N TI's story in the first movie just
like his father loar is a stranger to
the Met cayena Clan but learns their
ways and charms a Chief's daughter he
also befriends a dangerous and sacred
animal that they rever and is told I See
You by reyer in a direct Echo alien
that's all they see I see you drawing
the sequence when a wailing vessel
slowly Turns Upside Down lowak and Rea
end up precariously birched right on top
of it as it submerges in the water just
like Jack and Rose in Titanic they
promise to hold on to each other when
they take the plunge what's James
Cameron up to one of the strangest
scenes in avatar The Way of water is
when Norman Max fly out to the islands
to try and see what's going on with Kiri
who had a seizure while connected to the
meteno version of the spirit tree
attaching dios and machines to kiri's
head Norm speculates that a spiritual
connection to AWA may be a side effect
of epilepsy it's an Abrupt and strange
suggestion after lots of evidence that
there may be nothing special about Kiri
at all this flies in the face of the
genuinely faithful with nature of both
Avatar movies and never gets followed up
on in general the spiritual purity of
the na'vi and the real world influence
of AA is imper obvious in the first
movie The na'vi basically are losing the
fight until AA intervenes and possesses
all the animal life on the planet to
attack the human forces Avatar as a
franchise seems to have no interest in
sincerely exploring the delicate balance
between science and Faith this scene
which dabbles in skepticism just for the
sake of a distraction is one of the
dumbest things of in the way of water
most people don't go to the movies to
read so subtitles can often be a deal
breaker when you're browsing the Netflix
menu as Jake suly learned the ways of
the omaya clan of the na'vi in the first
Avatar the movie was committed to
showing both English and na'vi being
spoken consistently and subtitling the
alien dialogue whenever necessary the
way language was treated was logical and
consistent but in the way of water
director James Cameron and Company must
have realized early on that since Jake
has now been living with the na'vi for
more than a decade they would
essentially be making a foreign language
film to solve this very early in the
sequel Jake tells us via voice over that
he's learned the na'vi language so
thoroughly that when he hears it it may
as well be English and Presto suddenly
we also hear his children and all other
na'vi speaking English when na'vi
interact with other English-speaking
characters later they're still subtitled
but whenever na'vi are talking to each
other it's all English for convenience's
sake it does save the audience a lot of
subtitle read
but it's a bracingly dumb and inelegant
tweak to the rules of the way the
reality of what we're seeing being
depicted after the earnest Pride that
the first avatar took in realizing na'vi
culture it's kind of surprising that the
way of water just shrugs and transforms
90% of potentially Navy dialogue into
plain old
[Music]
English